Hey, what's up guys?
Thanks for joining us on The King of Random.
Batteries are everywhere and we use them in all sorts of stuff,
and a lot of the time they come with warnings
saying to make sure you dispose of them properly, and how they can be dangerous if you misuse them.
Well today, we are going to take this group of batteries
and we're gonna run them through a series of
destruction tests to see what happens if you stab them, cut them open, smash them, or even burn them
So let's get started. Not too long ago
I tried using a nail to slightly dent a battery to help balance a homo-polar motor. Well now
I'm gonna see what happens if I take a nail and
drive it as far as I can into the battery; not just denting it on the top.
Ooh, it's leaking something already. There is liquid coming out of this battery.
Well, that's a good start. Let's keep driving the nail and see what keeps happening.
I'll be honest. I didn't really think that the nail was gonna be able to drive this far into the battery.
That is pretty much all the way through it, and it's still leaking.
We've got this liquid leaking out, which I believe is potassium hydroxide, which is supposed to be fairly
irritating if you get it on your skin, so try and avoid touching this stuff. Our battery is also getting pretty warm.
I'm gonna hit it with this little laser thermometer.
120 Fahrenheit. The battery is getting quite hot now. As a comparison, if I take a scan of a block of metal next to it
That's at 65.
The battery is at 135 still heating up pretty warm to the touch
36 I'm just gonna stand back a little bit and let it go and see if anything keeps happening to it as it warms up
like this
See if I can take an accurate measurement from this far away
showing 145 now
Well if I get closer it's showing 166 let me try and pull the nail out
There's a battery with a hole in it, I think it's cooling down a little bit now
feels kind of oily
Not like really oily, but a little oily all right well
I'm gonna try that exact same thing, but I'm gonna drive the nail in from the other side
More oozing liquid
Going in a weird angle here see if I can straighten this out.
Oh and since there's a hole I can now go all the way through my thermometer is showing that it's up to a hundred degrees Fahrenheit
Watch it just climbing in temperature our other battery got up to
166 on here and now we're only hitting 116, so it's definitely warm, but it's not as hot as the other one
Now I've driven a nail through either end of the battery
I think it's only fair that I try and drive one right through the side
Its warming up again just hit a hundred degrees Fahrenheit. Ooo something just made a fizzle noise.
It's a liquid inside the battery is spurting out onto the nail. It's occasionally making a hissing sound
past 130 Fahrenheit
140, More hissing and bubbling
Seems to be Hovering right around 150 now and once again
We have a battery with a hole running right through it
Holding it still for a couple seconds. It really does start to heat up in the hand well
I would say that being stabbed with a nail is definitely not good for batteries
Now since it should be a fun way to destroy it and I want a good look at what's inside
I'm gonna take a hacksaw and cut this C cell battery down in half lengthwise
(Sawing noises)
There's our black liquid oozing out
All right, I've got there's a black paste just all over the blade of the hacksaw now turn this upside down
Cutting through it from the other side
I think I've got it
Mmm. Gross well, I've got a gooey paste here and a
Slightly less gooey paste here
Smells a little bit like ammonia
This paste looks like it's full of little metal flecks. I need to do some research and find out. What is inside a battery
This rod is coming from the negative terminal so this rod clearly goes down into this silvery paste
You know about about the consistency of toothpaste. I'd say maybe a little bit thinner it's like really really compacted
dirt kind of texture
metal shell
There you go guys a c cell battery probably a little bit difficult to fit inside your remote-control car at this point
Our next method of destruction might not be quite so eventful, but I've always wondered
what would happen if you just took two 9-volt batteries and
Plug them into each other and just let them sit. I'm sure you're not supposed to do that
Let's find out why?
All right, those are now providing feedback into each other now. I'm just gonna check with the thermometer
What temperature they're getting to?
I'll see if they are warming up a little bit of time
75.
Some part of the battery is a lot warm. That's measuring 85
There's different temperatures different parts parts of it at about
80 right now other parts are over 90
Oh
Over a hundred Fahrenheit now. That's interesting one of our batteries is considerably warmer than the other
This battery is only measuring at about 85 right now. This battery is measuring in at about a hundred and five
Serious the gloves do insulate a little bit
So it's hard to tell for sure
But I think this one does feel warmer thats warm enough to cook a steak if you like it rare
Next up. We've got a 20 ton shop press
So we're gonna see what happens if we put a couple different types of battery under that and just squish 'em
We've made contact now the squishing begins well that circle might just bite right into the battery
We've got some stuff oozing out good amount of stuff oozing out on the back all right
I think that's about as flat this jack is gonna get it
It's pretty squished
It actually bounced back a little bit after being squished
Definitely see some of the innards of it
Now I've got a C cell battery under here, let's squish that down and see what happens
It's definitely deforming sideways, so I'm pretty sure it's just gonna pop out in a second
Or, it's just gonna burst and squirt liquid really far. That was exciting
Wow. It really is like toothpaste being squeezed out.
It is obliterated; quite, completely obliterated.
This squished C cell battery is
probably just as broken as the one we cut in half.
That really just oozed out there kind of like toothpaste at one point that was fun now for our next type of destruction
I'm gonna try hitting a few different types of batteries with a blowtorch
I've got our 9-volt battery a normal double a battery and then I also have a lithium
Double-a battery which does contain lithium and should burn very brightly and possibly with interesting colors
We'll see if it actually burns through to the lithium well enough to ignite it
Not sure if it'll work or not as you can see I'm also now wearing a jacket and that's just for protection in case something
Burns or shoots hot liquid at me. I just want a little bit more protection. I'm gonna start out with the 9-volt.
I am nervous doing this holding it this close to me. Alright, I was a little too nervous
just holding that battery like that so I've now got the system set up so I can just set the torch on the battery and
then safely back away. Let's give a shot.
Got a little glowing orange spot.
The bottom seems nice and hot, but it doesn't actually look like it's doing too much.
Certainly some flames coming out of it.
Boozing out the back it just seems like the whole batteries kind of on fire
Alright let's turn that off for a bit.
That's some interesting colors right there.
Sort of a bright, glowing smoke for a second. That was interesting and we got these
smaller piles inside.
I didn't think this type of battery worked like that.
I think each of these is a one and a half volt battery,
and there's six of them, which gives us our 9-volt battery power
Let's try it with our other types of battery and see what happens.
Well it's peeling away the wrapper on the battery pretty instantly.
It's starting to leak pretty quick
Much faster reaction than the last one that's for sure. It smells awful too.
Timber!
Let's try our lithium battery
Once again, the outside gets destroyed immediately.
Woah!
I think it lit. Okay!
And now it's. . .  no now it lit. Now it lit.
That's amazing!
That's fantastic!
What even just happened? Look how pink that it is.
It was just. . .  it's magenta colored. It's not a normal fire color.
There's still something melting on the back.
I don't know what liquid that is that's boiling and bubbling there.
Now I just have like this glowing orange, I don't know it it's like glossy on the outside.
Inside these lithium batteries there actually is a strip of lithium metal, and we're gonna see if we can take that out.
That's what's causing the bright magenta flames.
There we go that whole thing so there you have just coils of metal strips inside there,
and one of those strips is lithium. This whole wad of. . .
There we go.
This one I believe is not our lithium
I don't know exactly what metal it is probably aluminum, then here inside our plastic. That is a strip of lithium metal
very lightweight like
More than aluminum. It feels like. This feels super, super light.
Also tears very easily, it's
really soft. You can see how easily it wrinkles and everything. This is, this feels thicker than aluminum foil.
But it's at least as soft. Maybe softer all right. Let's light this little piece of it off
You can see how magenta those flames are and then when it really ignites it gets very bright
That's melting into our fire brick if I can put another piece of it on top of it
Yep
Really bright kind of hurts to look at it so bright
And it's like the the smoke is being lit up by the heat of it or something. That's pretty crazy
There you have it
We just destroyed a whole bunch of batteries in a whole bunch of ways. We stabbed,
cut, smashed, and burned our batteries to see what happens.
I can't say I really recommend doing this because then you don't have your batteries anymore.
Although burning the lithium batteries did look pretty cool.
We found that inside the batteries was a silvery paste and a black clay-like substance.
Cutting the battery in half really let us see the insides pretty well.
A nail driven through a battery caused a lot of leakage and
I'm sure the batteries don't work at all anymore.
And lighting the batteries on fire had different effects based on what type of battery they were.
Regular batteries just sort of burned up and maybe oozed out some of their liquid
and the lithium battery is popped and then burned a
Bright magenta color this really satisfied a lot of curiosity
I've had since I was a child and was told that you had to make sure you don't use damaged or dented batteries
because it could cause problems. well now, I've seen some of those problems that can happen
if you take them to an extreme.
I've really enjoyed this random destruction of these batteries. I hope you had a good time
Thanks for joining us for this video, and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to then.
Franken-battery
Smells like rotten eggs.
I don't think this one is actually gonna be very exciting. It's just yep. They're ruining each other.
Hey guys! If you are on Twitter, come follow me on Twitter: @thekingofrandom.
It's a great place to connect with me one-on-one.
And that's all I'm going to say about that, because if you want to you will.
And if you don't, you won't.
So I will see you there, or maybe I won't.